,
DANA PERINO, "THE FIVE."
PRESIDENT BIDEN STAYING UP WAY
PAST HIS BEDTIME TO WARN AMERICA
THAT DEMOCRACY IS ABOUT TO END
FOREVER.
AND THE ONLY WAY TO SAVE IT IS
TO KEEP DEMOCRATS IN POWER.
SURPRISED?
BECAUSE VOTING FOR REPUBLICANS
WILL DESTROY THE REPUBLIC AND
THE FABRIC OF SPACE AND TIME
ITSELF.
SAYING THAT CANDIDATES ARE
PUTTING UP AMERICA ON A PATH TO
CHAOS WHICH SOUNDS LIKE A PRETTY
GOOD HEAVY METAL BANDS.
>> A STRUGGLE FOR DEMOCRACY, A
STRUGGLE FOR DECENCY AND
DIGNITY.
A STRUGGLE FOR PROSPERITY AND
PROGRESS, A STRUGGLE FOR THE
VERY SOUL OF AMERICA ITSELF,
THIS IS A CHOICE WE CAN MAKE.
THIS UNION AND CHAOS ARE NOT
INEVITABLE.
THE REMARKABLE THING ABOUT
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY IS THIS, JUST
ENOUGH OF IT.
ON JUST ENOUGH OCCASIONS HAVE
CHOSEN NOT TO DISMANTLE
DEMOCRACY, BUT TO PRESERVE
DEMOCRACY.
WE MUST CHOOSE THAT PATH AGAIN.
BECAUSE DEMOCRACY IS ON THE
BALLOT.
>> ASTRONOMER ONCE SAID THAT
EXTRAORDINARY CLAIM REQUIRES
EXTRAORDINARY EVIDENCE, WHICH WE
ADD EXCEPT IN POLITICS WHEN YOU
ARE A DEMOCRAT, THEN YOU CAN SAY
THE VERY WORST THINGS POSSIBLE
WITHOUT A SHRED OF DATA.
BUT A NEFARIOUS SPEECH
REPUBLICANS ARE SUCH A THREAT,
WHY IS JOE BIDEN ONLY TALKING
ABOUT IT NOW THAT THEY GOT THERE
HANDED TO THEM.
AND GETTING THE EXACT
REPUBLICANS ON THE BALLOT, AND
IF YOU THOUGHT WHAT JOE BIDEN
SAID WAS EXTREME, THE MEDIA'S
FAVORITE SO-CALLED HISTORIAN AND
THE LADIES OF "TO THE VIEW" ARE
ABOUT TO MAKE HIM LOOK LIKE
MOTHER TERESA.
>> THEY WILL SAY WHAT WAS AT
STAKE TONIGHT AND THIS WEEK WAS
THE FACT OF WHETHER WE WOULD BE
A DEMOCRACY IN THE FUTURE?
WHETHER OUR CHILDREN WILL BE
ARRESTED AND ARRESTED AND
CONCEIVABLY KILLED.
WE ARE ON THE EDGE OF A BRUTAL
AUTHORITARIAN SYSTEM AND IT
COULD BE A WEEK AWAY.
>> YOU ARE VOTING FOR A COLD,
REMEMBER THAT.
IT IS A COLD, IT IS NOT
REPUBLICANS ANYMORE.
>> WHITE REPUBLICAN SUBURBAN
WHEN WOMEN ARE NOW GOING TO VOTE
REPUBLICAN.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE ROACHES VOTING
FOR RAID.
>> THAT IS INSULTING TO THE
VOTER.
>> Greg: WHEN SHE IS
PRETENDING TO THINK, SHE ALWAYS
LOOKS UP, THIS IS A MAJOR
MOMENT.
I KNOW THAT WHEN REPUBLICANS
WENT OUT AND KILL A BUNCH OF
KIDS, SO LET'S TALK TO THE TRUE
CAST MEMBER OF "THE FIVE"
JUDGE JEANINE HAD A LITTLE
SURGERY.
>> Judge Jeanine: I'M THRILLED
TO BE BACK, I DON'T LIKE STAYING
HOME AND WATCHING TELEVISION AND
EATING CANDY, DOES THAT MEAN
THAT I GET TO ANSWER FIRST?
YOU KNOW IT IS AMAZING ABOUT ALL
OF THIS IS IT WAS JOE BIDEN I
THINK THE FIRST ITERATION OF THE
"SPECIAL REPORT" STARTED TALKING
ABOUT STANDING THERE WITH THE
MILITARY BEHIND HIM AND THE
RED LIGHT SAYING THAT MILITARY
SUGGESTING THAT IT WOULD BE USED
AGAINST YOU IF YOU DON'T MAKE
SURE THAT YOU GET RID OF THESE
EXTREME SPEECH REPUBLICANS
73 MILLION PEOPLE WHO VOTED FOR
DONALD TRUMP, BUT I'M TIRED OF
THE SOUL OF THE NATION,
AMERICANS ARE TIRED OF THE SOUL
OF THE NATION AND IN THE END
THEY ARE ANGRY, THEY ARE ANGRY
BECAUSE THEY CAN AFFORD FOOD,
THEY CAN AFFORD GAS.
THEY CAN AFFORD TO PAY FOR THE
HEAT COMING UP THIS WINTER, AND
THE DEMOCRATS ARE ONLY TALKING
ABOUT IDEOLOGY.
AND THE AMAZING PART IS THEY
HAVE THE HOUSE, THE SENATE, THE
OVAL, THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA, BIG
TECH AND THEY STILL HAVE AN
AMERICA 80% OF WHOM THINKS
AMERICA IS NOT ON THE RIGHT
TRACK.
SO THEY ARE LOSING AND NOW THEY
ARE OFF THEIR ROCKER.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT THE MAN IS
OFF HIS ROCKER, AND BY THE WAY,
THE ONE THING THAT YOU MENTION,
GREG, IS THAT THEY ARE FUNDING
PEOPLE LIKE CARY LAKE.
THANK GOD, THE WOMAN IS A
SUPERSTAR.
SO THEY CAN COMPLAIN ALL THEY
WANT ABOUT WE ARE GOING TO KILL
PEOPLE AND THAT WE ARE GOING TO
ARREST PEOPLE, BUT THE TRUTH IS,
THEY ARE MISALIGNED WITH
AMERICANS AND WHAT WE WANT TO.
>> Greg: I FEEL LIKE I AM
READY TO ARM WRESTLE, YOUR HANDS
ARE UP LIKE THIS THE WHOLE TIME.
OVER-THE-TOP TWO WITH
JUDGE JEANINE.
IT IS TO BE ON ONE UPCOMING ONE
FEELS BETTER.
>> Jessica: DON'T BE SORRY, IT
LOOKS GREAT.
>> Judge Jeanine: IT LOOKS
AWFUL.
>> Jessica: IT DOES NOT.
>> Judge Jeanine: YOU
PREDICTED THIS WOULD BE A
DO-OVER OF THE CREEPY SPEECH HE
MADE, AND IT WAS, BUT IT HAD NO
ENERGY, HAD NO VIBE OTHER THAN
THIS KIND OF MOROSE SAD
DECEITFUL DODDERING OLD MAN.
>> Dana: NEEDED THAT SPEECH
RIGHT BEFORE LABOR DAY WEEKEND
AND IT WAS LIKE THAT'S WHERE
TIMING, AND THEN THIS ONE WAS
EVEN MORE WEIRD.
IT WAS LIKE THEY WOKE UP IN THE
MORNING AT THE WHITE HOUSE AND
SAID WE ARE IN BIG TROUBLE IN A
LOT OF PLACES THE ONLY THING WE
CAN DO IS MAY BE DUE ANOTHER ONE
OF THE SPEECHES AND SO THEN THEY
SHUT DOWN UNION STATION, AND IT
COULD NOT BELIEVE IT, AND
WATCHING PRIME TIME LAST NIGHT
AND JESSE SHOW POPS UP THE
PICTURE, THE VIDEO, AND I REALLY
HAD TO DO A DOUBLE TAKE.
I SAID OH, I THOUGHT IT WAS A
JOKE.
I REALLY THOUGHT IT WAS A JOKE,
BECAUSE HERE YOU SHUT DOWN THIS
BEAUTIFUL BUILDING, AND YOU HAVE
A BACKDROP THAT YOU COULD HAVE
BEEN GIVING A SPEECH IN OMAHA AT
THE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
IT LOOKS SO WEIRD.
I WAS LIKE I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
AND THEN THEY TOOK THE WIDE
SHOT, I JUST THINK THE
STAGECRAFT IS SO WEIRD.
PUT TOGETHER IN A STRANGE WAY
AND FELT LIKE IT AT 20 DIFFERENT
AUTHORS FOR ONE SPEECH AND KEPT
SAYING THE SAME THING OVER AND
OVER AGAIN.
>> Greg: THE SOUL OF THE
NATION COMES FROM SOMEBODY AND
IT IS MEANINGLESS, THERE IS NO
SOUL FROM A NATION.
>> Dana: ELISSA SLOTKIN IS ONE
OF THE DEMOCRATS LIKE ABIGAIL
SPANBERGER, WHERE SHE WAS QUOTED
IN A NEWSPAPER ARTICLE TODAY
SAYING THAT IN HER DISTRICT IN
MICHIGAN, AND SHE IS A DEMOCRAT,
SHE SAID THAT NO ONE IS TALKING
ABOUT THIS.
SHE SAID SEDATIVES ON THE RECORD
THAT NOBODY IS TALKING ABOUT THE
SENATE DOES NOT HELP ANY OF
THESE PEOPLE THAT ARE RUNNING.
LAST NIGHT MAGGIE HASSAN IS
RUNNING AGAINST GENERAL BALDOCK
AND SHE TRIED TO SAY OH, I
WORKED WITH TRUMP MORE THAN I
WORKED WITH BIDEN, SHE IS ON THE
RUN.
FINALLY THE LAST ONE I WANT TO
MAKE IS THAT BE SEVEN AND HARRIS
TRIED TO MAKE GEORGIA THE SOUL
OF THE NATION DEMOCRACY IS IN
TROUBLE, NO ONE IS GOING TO BE
ABLE TO VOTE, AND NOW YOU SEE IN
THESE EARLY VOTE TOTALS THAT
THEY ARE SURPASSING WHAT ANYBODY
EVER EXPECTED, ALMOST MORE THAN
A PRESIDENTIAL YEAR, AND I THINK
THAT NOW THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE
TO SERVE ON ELECTION NIGHT FOR
JOE BIDEN JIM CROW 2.0.
HOW IS THAT GOING TO TASTE?
>> Greg: IT WILL BE VERY
BITTER, IT WON'T TASTE LIKE JIM
EAGLE, IT'S DELICIOUS, JESSICA,
ARE YOU READY FOR A PERCEPTIVE
QUESTION?
>> Jessica: I GUESS SO.
>> Greg: IS IT WHAT JOE BIDEN
IS DOING TO A SEGMENT OF THE
AMERICAN POPULATION IN THE SAME
THING THAT KAMALA HARRIS DID TO
HIM IN THE DEBATE WHICH IS NOT
SAYING THE TRUTH, BUT JUST
PLAYING THE GAME?
I DON'T THINK THAT HE BELIEVES
ANYTHING HE IS SAYING AND THEN
AFTERWARDS WHEN THEY QUESTION
KAMALA HARRIS, YOU CALL THEM
RACIST, AND SHE LAUGHED, SHE
SAID IT'S JUST A DEBATE, ISN'T
THAT WHAT HE IS DOING?
SEE HIM THE TRUTH DOESN'T
MATTER, IT'S JUST TRYING TO WIN?
>> Jessica: I THINK THAT
KAMALA THOUGHT THAT THERE WERE
SEGREGATIONISTS AND PEOPLE
WANTED BOSS BLACK KIDS AROUND,
AND THEY THINK THAT THERE ARE
GENUINE THREATS TO OUR
DEMOCRACY, THAT IS A TACTIC AND
ELECTIONS THAT I NEVER
SUPPORTED, BECAUSE IF EVEN ONE
OF THEM WINS, THEN IT IS UNDONE
THE ENTIRE --
>> Greg: APOLOGY ACCEPTED,
JESSICA.
>> Jessica: SOUL OF THE NATION
AND TALKING ABOUT ELECTION
NIHILISM AND THE IMPORTANCE OF
DEMOCRACY IS A PRESIDENTIAL
ISSUE, IT IS NOT A MIDTERM
ISSUE.
AND THAT'S WHERE IT IS JUST OUT
OF PLACE, AND HE HAS BEEN
CONSISTENTLY TALKING ABOUT THIS
SINCE JANUARY 6, THIS IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT IS OUT OF THE
BLUE.
BUT MIDTERM ELECTIONS ARE ABOUT
THE KITCHEN TABLE ALWAYS, WHICH
IS WHY THE PRESIDENT IN POWER
LOSES THE MIDTERM ELECTION RIGHT
AFTER.
AND I THINK THAT IT WAS A REAL
MISSED OPPORTUNITY ON THAT
FRONT, AND BARACK OBAMA, AND I
HAVE SEEN A LOT OF PEOPLE ON TV
LATELY TALKING ABOUT HOW MANY
SEATS HE LOST AND THAT'S
ABSOLUTELY TRUE DOWN TILL STATE
LEGISLATURE UP TO THE SENATE,
BUT HE UNDERSTANDS WHAT YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE TALKING ABOUT
NOW, AND YES, IT DOES MATTER
THAT PEOPLE DON'T RESPECT THEIR
ELECTION LAWS, BUT WHAT MATTERS
MORE IS THAT PEOPLE ARE
CONCERNED AT THE GAS PUMP, THEY
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
THANKSGIVING.
THERE WAS THAT NEW SURVEY THAT
ONE IN FIVE PEOPLE FEEL THAT
THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
COMPROMISE THEIR THANKSGIVING
PLANS.
THOSE ARE THINGS THAT PEOPLE
REMEMBER GOING FORWARD.
SO SHOULD HAVE GONE TO THE
PHILLIES GAME, BUT JOE BIDEN
WENT, SHE SHOWED UP IN THE THIRD
INNING.
>> Greg: AND LEFT IN THE
FIFTH, WE NOTICED I WAS GOING TO
QUOTE CARL SAGAN AND YOU SAID HE
IS YOUR FAVORITE ASTRONOMER,
WHAT IS YOUR FAVORITE BOOK?
IT'S BECAUSE THEY ARE SO MANY OF
THEM, THAT I CAN'T PUT MY FINGER
ON IT.
HIS LATEST ONE.
>> Greg: HE PASSED AWAY.
>> Jesse: THE LAST ONE HE
WROTE BEFORE HE PASSED AWAY.
VOTERS WANT SOMETHING WITH
TEETH, YOU CAN'T GET OUT THERE
AND SAY DEMOCRACY IS GOING TO
DIE IF WE VOTE REPUBLICAN AND
NOT EXPLAIN HOW IS IT GOING TO
DIE.
A REPUBLICAN IS GOING TO CANCEL
THE NEXT ELECTION?
IS MITCH McCONNELL GOING TO
TELL GAVIN NEWSOM HE IS NOT
ALLOWED TO RUN FOR PRESIDENT?
AS MUCH AS I WOULD LIKE THAT,
THAT'S PREPOSTEROUS.
DEMOCRATS KNOW IT'S
PREPOSTEROUS, BECAUSE IF THEY
THOUGHT THIS WAS GOING TO BE A
CASE, THEY WOULD BE AHEAD IN
EARLY VOTING.
EVEN MSNBC DOES NOT BUY IT,
GREG, AND THEY WILL BUY
ANYTHING.
THIS GUY IS CAMPAIGNING ON THE
LAST ELECTION AND THE NEXT
ELECTION.
AND IN 2022 IT'S LIKE, JOE, WE
ARE OVER HERE!
FOCUS ON ME!
THE GUY HAS LOCKED HIMSELF IN
DELAWARE FOR MONTHS AND HE IS
DODDERING ABOUT MAGA, MAGA,
MAGA, AND PEOPLE ALIKE CAN YOU
LOWER THE PRICES?
AND I HEAR THIS, GREG, THIS IS
AN INFLECTION POINT, IF I HEAR
DEMOCRACY OR AUTOCRACY ONE MORE
TIME I WILL FALL OFF MY CHAIR.
HE PLAGIARIZED IT AND HITS IT
OVER THE HEAD WITH US LIKE A
NUTTY PROFESSOR.
WE DON'T WANT TO HEAR THAT
LECTURE.
WE WANT TO HEAR WHAT YOU ARE
ACTUALLY GOING TO DO.
AND HE ACTUALLY SOUNDS LIKE HE
IS A COMMUNIST CHINESE LEADER,
BECAUSE HE IS THE ONE RETAINING
HIS OPPONENTS HOUSE, HE IS THE
ONE CENSORING FREE SPEECH ON THE
INTERNET AND I JUST CAN'T WAIT
FOR OUR VERY OWN STUPID SON OF A
BITCH THE DAY AFTER THE ELECTION
TO STATE OF THE PRESS SECRETARY,
WE HAVE A RIGHT WAY OF, IS
DEMOCRACY DEAD?
AND I CAN'T WAIT TO HEAR WHAT
SHE SAYS.
>> Greg: IF A WHITE FEMALE
HOST COMPARED BLACK WOMEN TO
ROACHES, IMAGINE.
>> Dana: SHE REALLY NEEDS TO
ASK PERMISSION BEFORE SHE MAKES
AN ANALOGY.
>> Greg: PROBABLY FORGIVEN